this is the public face of the election
tightly-controlled rallies the
monotonous repetition of key phrases
strong and stable government but the
real battle is happening elsewhere
underground unseen the invisible
election where everybody is being
measured followed and man marked for
their views and how they might change
everybody in the country given a score
on their likelihood to vote for a party
views on brexit and likelihood to get to
the ballot box using data from finance
companies insurance companies and social
media then the right people mums dads
pensioners parents in the right houses
on the right streets in the right wards
of the right constituencies are targeted
with personalized messages it's totally
non transparent that is if a party has a
billboard or a party political broadcast
on the television everybody sees it they
know what they're saying to people and
they can assess that accordingly but on
a social media platform it's happening
in a closed secret world that's unique
to one very small group of people and we
just don't know what those
advertisements are saying or how they're
targeting people or whether they or
their accuracy we don't we don't know
anything about them and I think that's
what's different and that's what's
worrying all of this might just be the
modern-day equivalent of the billboard
but after the last general election the
Electoral Commission said it all needs
to be regulated and yet because of the
snap election it isn't going to be
I think the Electoral Commission would
say themselves that they don't know very
much about what's going on and that they
find it very difficult to place any
checks and balances on it and I think
that's something that we ought to be
looking at at the last election such
targeting of adverts explained how the
Conservatives managed to turn around
very large Lib Dem majorities first of
all canvasses such as these in January
2015
identified people who are not
conservative supporters but could be
squeezed through fear of Ed Miliband and
the SNP at number 10 then targeted ads
in the constituency if you were older on
pensions and the NHS and younger it was
on schools funding some would get
personalized letters from David Cameron
it helps the conservative campaign beat
the national swing in the seats it
needed for a majority in 2015 the leave
campaign did the same thing one is being
investigated the government also paid
for such targeting in the remain camp -
and Donald Trump used such profiling to
drum up support in his shock election
win this micro targeting is now an
inescapable part of our elections but it
is in the dark with implications for our
democracy